The final type of data we'll talk about is
time series data. Time series data is simply a
collection of observations obtained through repeated measurements over time.
In plain English, a time series is simply a sequence
of numbers collected at regular intervals over some period
of time. For example, we might measure the average number
of home runs per players for many different years.
Time series data is not so different from numerical data.
The real difference here is that rather then having a
bunch of numerical values which don't have any time ordering,
time series data does have some implied ordering. There's a
first data point collected and a last data point collected.